the universe is a tremendous structure
comprised of an infinite multitude of
all sorts of diverse objects
they lie so far apart in endless
expanses of space that even light gets
lost in their depths
it takes a photon traveling from the sun
over four years to reach our nearest
star
as for covering intergalactic distances
it takes millions of years when you
realize that all this enormous distance
is just a tiny molecule on the scale of
macrocosmos it can't but amaze
so what is the real size of the universe
cosmo the first in outer space
the solar system is just one of the
countless multitude of planetary systems
scattered across our galaxy
as we know it consists of a single star
in its main sequence stage and date
planets with their satellites
in addition our system contains over a
million small celestial bodies like
asteroids comets and meteoroids the
planet in the solar system lying
furthest at least that we know of is
neptune
its orbits radius measures around 30
astronomical units which is equivalent
to approximately four light hours
amazingly only a tiny portion of the
solar system is encompassed by neptune's
orbit
the remotest object in the system
discovered to date is the so-called far
far out lying 132 astronomical units or
18 light hours away from the sun
still even this object barely visible
against a dark background of
unfathomable space is not at all close
to the hypothetical oort cloud whose
inner boundaries lie approximately 2 000
astronomical units away from the center
of our system
according to some estimates its outer
boundaries stretch for up to 60 000
astronomical units at the very least
which is around one light year
these limits are predefined by the sun's
gravitational influence and what lies
beyond is interstellar space
moving further away we will notice over
50 of all kinds of stars within 20
light-years from the sun
these stars are really diverse
from dim and cold brown dwarfs to bright
and widely known objects like sirius
procyon and daltair
some of them have their own planetary
systems with objects potentially capable
of nursing and sustaining life
for example the object known as gliese
832c
which is 16.1 light years away from the
sun is similar to our earth more than
any other planet within the solar system
that we know of
the average temperature on the
exoplanet's surface reaches 253 kelvin
or 20 degrees celsius below zero and it
takes the astronomical body just 36
earth days to complete a full orbit
around its parent star
in astronomical standards the distance
between us and gliese 832c is relatively
small
however a space probe setting out from
our system at a speed of roughly 17
kilometers per second would take as much
as 300 000 years to reach the
exoplanet's environs
at our current level of technological
advancement it is impossible to design
an interstellar spaceship capable of
completing as long a journey as that
the solar system together with its
neighbor stars is part of the orion arm
the latter in its turn is part of the
milky way
it contains around 400 billion stars and
potentially over a trillion exoplanets
of all sorts can be discovered there
according to estimates today the main
diameter of the milky way measures
around a hundred thousand light years
and the stellar halo may be twice as
large even though the thickness of the
main disc measures about a thousand
light years there is a clearly defined
bulge in the galaxy's center
this bulge is roughly 3000 light years
thick
the milky way is part of the so-called
local group
this is a vast structure comprising over
50 galaxies concentrated within an area
of space measuring around 10 million
light years in diameter
the andromeda galaxy the triangulum
galaxy and the milky way are the largest
of the lot
some estimates show that the mass total
of the cluster may reach as much as 3
trillion solar masses with our galaxy
and andromeda accounting for the major
part
with the distance from the earth to
andromeda around 2.5 million light years
it is considered to be our closest
galaxy not counting smaller or dwarf
ones
moving on to the next order the local
group forms part of the giant virgo
supercluster made up of over 30 000
galaxies the supercluster is located
within an area of space with a diameter
of around
150 million light years
its mass total is as much as a
quadrillion solar masses
or in other words
around a thousand galaxies like the
milky way
the supercluster is quite flattened and
around 60 percent of all the objects it
is made up of appear like a flat sheet
around 10 million light-years thick
staggering though it may appear on the
face of it
this value is actually small in terms of
the large-scale structure of the
universe
as we zoom out still more we have a
chance of seeing a giant supercluster of
galaxies approximately 520 million light
years in size
called laniakea it includes several
galaxy superclusters
among others the virgo supercluster and
the great attractor
the overall mass of this formation
measures approximately as much as a
hundred quadrillion solar masses the
great attractor lies roughly 250 million
light years away from our planet and is
the gravitational center for all objects
lying close by astronomical standards
it cannot be observed from the earth
directly as the milky way is plain
thwarts it that is why the nature of the
great attractor still remains an
unsolved mystery today
[Music]
laniakea is part of the large-scale
structure of the universe an elaborate
system of galactic filaments walls and
voids gargantuan areas of emptiness in
space
some of these objects are really
incredibly enormous
for example the hercules corona borealis
great wall stretches for around a
staggering 10 billion light years ever
since its discovery in 2013 this
superstructure has been considered the
most gigantic component of the
large-scale structure of the universe to
all appearances it must be home to
millions of galaxies
and the number of stars it contains will
probably always defy calculation
the mere existence of a structure like
that is a mystery to science as
according to today's accepted theory of
universe's evolution
gargantuan clusters like that are simply
not supposed to form
but incidentally this wall so enormous
that the human brain cannot fully
appreciate its dimensions is still just
a tiny portion of the observable
universe
according to today's cosmological
notions
space in the universe is continually
expanding
with the speed of expansion depending on
the distance between objects the further
an observed object lies away from the
observer the faster the distance between
the two increases
the rate at which the two mutually
recede is not limited by the speed of
light because it's actually space matter
that is expanding
which means that at a certain point the
two objects will be mutually
unobservable
relic radiation observation shows that
the area of the observable universe is a
sphere
with a diameter roughly 93 billion light
years
according to the theory of relativity we
can see and interact with only those
objects that are within this sphere this
conventional spherical area in space is
called the meta galaxy and it may be
either all of the universe or again its
tiny portion
for all we know hypothetically there may
well lie some unknown structures beyond
the visible boundaries of space
such entities are referred to as extra
metagalactic objects and unfortunately
it is impossible to study them today
with scientific methods
still some astronomical bodies on the
edge of the visible universe appear to
be moving in ways different from what we
would naturally expect judging by the
data we have
instances of anomalous movements like
those may be evidence of the presence of
some massive structures beyond the
matter galaxy boundaries their
attraction pervades the space around and
influences objects around too
there is a whole plethora of hypotheses
as to the structure of the universe
beyond the meta galaxy but most of them
are rather of metaphysical nature
for example some people believe that
time and space as we more or less know
them are non-existent beyond the
boundaries of the universe
the physical laws we're used to do not
apply there either and notions of matter
material or energy are virtually
senseless
this hypothesis is further elaborated on
by the following idea
the meta galaxy accounts for just a part
of a yet more complex and larger scale
superstructure in space whose makeup and
dimensions are too incredible for us to
imagine it is quite possible that this
structure could be in a
multi-dimensional space
or else be based on physical principles
we have no idea of
this makes the meta galaxy just an
insignificant addition to or a partial
reflection of this mind-boggling
superstructure
according to some interpretations of the
anthropic principle there are other
worlds out there beyond the boundaries
of the observable universe
in those worlds the values of the
fundamental constants like the speed of
light or the electron charge are
completely different
this hypothesis is in many ways
supported by the idea of a multiverse
which schematically appears as foam with
lots of bubbles separated from each
other by thin walls but these walls are
impenetrable
this makes every universe a separate
space
with its own physical laws
and for all we know these laws may be
totally different from the ones we're
used to
the most radical hypotheses go as far as
to deny our world any objective reality
whatsoever
according to these the universe is just
a simulation like virtual reality in
computers but on an incredibly advanced
level
as a rule
ideas like that imply that there is some
super beings or super civilizations out
there beyond the reality we're used to
whose level of advancement is infinitely
higher than ours and whose goals and
capabilities are arcane and
incomprehensible however it goes without
saying that it is hardly possible to
either confirm or repudiate these
hypotheses
[Music]
of course distances in space defy our
imagination and are even frightening
they appear infinite from the point of
view of any person today
what we do know is that the universe is
expanding and provided this process
continues there will come a point when
space objects will disappear one after
another beyond the event horizon
first galaxies then stars and the world
will immerse in eternal darkness
but by then there will be no one around
to witness that
foreign